hey everybody and welcome to
a crazy wild ride we're gonna hear more
about the mexican mafia
than we are supposed to hear i'm pretty
sure
and we're talking to a legend man danny
trejo
snoop dogg says he and danny trejo are
the oldest gangsters in hollywood
and this guy is the real deal
man i love this episode so let's get
into
it yeah dude
what's up i've crashed more cars than
you
um
[Laughter]
yeah let's not waste anybody's time over
here you ready to go danny
ready okay this is how we do it
ladies and gentlemen danny trejo
yeah dude i want you to meet my co-host
scott randolph hey danny
scott what's up not much and up at the
front of the van we got the gorgeous
paul briskey
hello mr trejo nice to meet you check
paul's voice
yeah right thank you so jealous of it um
gotta say danny you've been on my list
you've been even on my list of like the
guys i most want to talk to on here so
thank you so much for doing this
thank you thank you man do you realize
that right now
your new movie star crawler
arrow is doing the song for that okay
who's star crawler arrow hey
star caller is the band arrow is the
girl that's singing
okay awesome excellent and is that gonna
be uh a cover of uh if you're gonna be
dumb you gotta be tough
yeah how about that that's super cool
man
right on dude yay remember that
i got connections always so don't ask me
anything [ __ ] up
i know dude i don't want to get on the
other side
are you in pacoima right now are you in
l.a well i'm in mission hills right now
the beverly hills of pacoima i love it
there you go
i love it yeah i've been looking at
property and i'm i'm i'm thinking about
buying over in that area it's beautiful
you know what the good thing is that
we got the the big lots you know it's
like the last place in
california you get big logs yeah right
by shadow hills you got the big horse
properties and
yeah for sure that's so cool man i
really enjoyed your documentary
we uh this is an rv that we do we do our
little podcast in but one night we set
up uh
the tv mountain on the outside we all
had uh
our little camping chairs and we watched
it and we were just like damn that was
great
yeah it was kind of cool it was a lot of
fun doing it i just wrote a book
it's called trejo the uh what is it the
art of
crime the art of crime
what's called the art of crime crime
redemption in hollywood i just put the
art because
crime is the art
that's that's fantastic so so uh is the
book available
it's not available yet july 4th july 6th
things
as the time of the release of this
podcast that book
is available available so yeah
i love it man yeah get your ass on over
to is it available everywhere the books
are available
yes yes now i'm interested in this
because i i got a new book i'm
working on as well are you trying to
push people towards brick and mortar
stores
are you trying to get them to buy it
online like uh
is there a way that you're encouraging
people to
to purchase the book i don't know
i think brick and mortar in that prison
he's like i got out of breaking more
years ago
yeah i mean i guess as long as the sales
count towards the the nielsen
the nielsen rating oh yeah the or the
you know whatever it is
but uh so
so dude you are all over the place in
los
angeles with these restaurants and and
coffee place how many of these do you
have now
we got four restaurants right now we had
seven but
we closed two during the pandemic simply
because
of the location one was on the bottom of
a an office building that shut down so
nobody was in there and then uh and the
other one was in the pasadena playhouse
and they stopped having play you know
completely so
uh we've closed those two and then but
right now we just opened up
another one in uh santa monica on third
and santa monica boulevard right by the
promenade
and we've got hold it ghost kitchens on
the west side
redwood city pasadena chicago and miami
and i'm visiting miami ghost kitchen
is that like a pop-up and you're going
to be there for a week or what is that
it's like what it is it's kind of like
five restaurants in one spot
and they deliver and stuff you know it's
like but i'll be there
i'll go there for a week or so okay cool
man so
uh dude when are you going to miami i'm
not sure
we just you know just started doing this
again that dude how did the idea come up
for you to open restaurants i mean it's
obviously working so well but it seems a
little bit counter-intuitive
you know what it's a complete uh
joke not joker it was like an accident
i did a low everything good that has
happened to me has happened as a direct
result of helping someone else
everything i did a low budget movie for
this
director named uh craig moss all right
great i didn't know him i didn't know he
was right and uh
and uh i had another chance to do one
for about 25 grand
right and but my agent gloria
kept you know this might turn into
something really good it's a good
literally you know how asians are and i
go
yeah but sweetheart this guy more money
over here
i know danny but i got a feeling and you
know that look that women give you when
they they're telling you you know why
don't you go die and
that well okay don't say i didn't say
warn you right right so okay let's do
this
[ __ ] so we did this low-budget movie
called badass
turns into a trilogy make four times the
money i was gonna make on this thing
and and it turned out badass
badasses badass on the bayou turned into
a [ __ ] and movie
everybody saw it and then and then uh
but on the first one badass the director
saw that i like
to eat good food and on a low budget
movie you don't always have the best
catering
you know they'll be go get mickey d's
get 50 hamburgers you know
and uh get the gag get the three for one
yeah
the bun and some meat and uh
and so i would order this producer ash
shaw saw that i would order
good food i'd have my assistant go get
me some good food some more
you know and uh and he said danny you
like to eat good i go
[ __ ] 74 years old you better eat good
yeah i mean
and and so i would eat healthy and uh
he said why don't you open a restaurant
so jokingly
i said try those tacos because first of
all like i see like a big diamond
t t you know what i mean look like a
rapper big t
t look who you know and my mom and i
always
pissed off my dad talking about a
restaurant because
my mom was a good cook but my dad
was kind of like the mexican archery
bunker you know
women stayed in the house and uh
and every time we talked about it hey
hey hey i gotta
i gotta keep it merrick right there in
the kitchen go cook whatever the hell
you want yeah i mean
and uh so that was the restaurant for us
you know
when i said treyos tacos we did badass
badasses
bad asses on the bayou when we did that
he brought me a business plan
now i don't know if you're like this but
i open the page if i don't see at least
one killing in the first page
it's not worth reading and there better
be some mayhem on this day
so i gave it to gloria she looked at it
says a no-brainer
let's do it because they're not asking
for 50 grand up front
they're not saying you have to make this
many appearances
they just want to open a restaurant so
we opened up
a restaurant on la brea between
that turned in you better stop [ __ ]
[Laughter]
it turned into a golem it's a whoa all
of a sudden all these
because that that thoroughfare right
there everybody stopped
and uh and so uh uh
then we opened up uh hollywood then we
opened up you and
we actually wanted i've actually gone in
there
that's a killer and paul orders
trejo's tacos constantly by postmates
when his wife
at least once a week if not five times a
week like uh
i love it everybody keeps asking me
what's your secret what's
i said no secrets good food man what are
you talking about people don't come back
for bad food and i eat them i eat for
free but
i get and i send friends of mine and
going on incognito
right and they go in and order and uh
and uh
pay and everything they all come back
with good you know with good reports and
so
it's funny because that my staff's danny
stop sending your friends in okay
we know who they are they scare
everybody
don't send the guy with a tattoo a san
quentin gun tower on his neck
and so uh you know it's like that's it
good
food and we've been successful and i
think one of the reasons is
we never stopped giving food during the
pandemic to the homeless
hospitals and and uh we fed all the
first responders
and all the gangsters hey why you
feeding the cubs shut up fool cause
they're
keeping you out of jail you idiot you
don't know yeah
so we got all the first responders all
the cops and we went to their uh
command center and they were shocked
danny trejo
what a guy man he makes me feel good you
know what else makes me feel good
wearing underwear from me undies i'm
telling you it just makes my
butt feel sexy the fabric is so
breathable and soft i don't think
there's any more
comfortable underwear in the world and
if you disagree
then they got a money-back guarantee
they will refund or replace
anything that you buy that's how much
they believe in it
and i love this company man plus they've
got this cool membership
program where they send you a crazy new
pair of boxer briefs
every month and dude it's rad
so let's get you on there all right
we're going to get you 15
off plus free shipping on your first
order
when you go to meetundies.com
stevo i'm telling you you gotta get into
these underwear because they are
so comfortable plus they're sustainably
made
and impossibly stylish so
enjoy 15 off your first order plus free
shipping
and get yourself some cool ass underwear
man
go to meetundies.com
stevo get styling get comfortable
and get friendly to the environment yeah
now let's talk about danny trejo
you know because i don't think anybody
was helping him we fed him
great taco do you ever bring tacos to
the prisons that you visit it's
you know yeah you can't take food you
can't take food in there yeah but
i you know when i go i go uh i love
going there you know i love going there
i keep telling them all hey you first
died out come out
join me yeah dude so it sounds like you
have a
a good relationship with cops these days
but i assume it wasn't
always that way was there kind of a
switch where you started seeing them as
as friends or as people and not as like
your enemy or as the people who are
locking you up you know
and you know what let me just there
could be 30 of us standing on the street
and cops would roll up in every hey you
come here
what come on pick one of these suckers
but i just had the face that said
i did something wrong you know and so
you know
yeah i had a bad relationship with them
and then here
it's like if you're not doing nothing
wrong
they don't give a [ __ ] about you know
what i mean it's like yeah well they're
always piggy
now they ain't gonna stop me if i don't
do anything wrong hey what's up
i was doing 80 miles an hour on the
diamond lane i was checking i got a 65
buick riviera right and i'm jam wow on
the diamond lane
and i'm by myself the hyrule
cop rolls up behind me man god damn
highway patrol
stop me god trail what the [ __ ] you got
in this thing
because we were doing buddy i said man i
started telling him he was a car buff
and
stay off the diamond lane let me go
there you go
yeah yeah i noticed as soon as i got
eight years sober and as soon as i got
sober like i stopped hating
cops and i was like well because i've
got it i've got it
i'm not getting in trouble anymore you
know what that's the whole deal
it's like you know i've been i mean i've
been stopped and
hey what's up give an autographed
picture or whatever
i uh we feed them we just we just came
down
yesterday oh from uh um palmdale we did
a big fundraiser for
uh police the sheriff police up there
for their all the kids in
trouble up there so you know they call
me for everything you know
you know they mean they're say kids and
yeah i'm there
yeah so you said san
quentin and that's the prison where you
were
the boxing champion of the whole prison
yeah the same quentin boxing champion in
soledad i was trying facility champion
uh there was
all three because solidarity has three
penitentiaries central
south uh and and north and uh
yeah i was trying a facility champion so
that was kind of cool
can you help me understand what uh the
boxing organization of
of uh san quentin or solid dad prisons
looks like do they have like
are there refs like if there's a ring
like
no they had scheduled fight we'd have
like fights with the
the the army and the navy would come in
sometimes
we uh we
do they would be exhibitions you know
but the only problem
is if damn mexicans don't understand the
exhibition
you know they'll come we got money on
your home no wait it's an exhibition
no hey don't buy we got money almost and
so you either had to tell the guy that
you were fighting look
go for what you know you know or
surprise him you know i mean if he
looked up surprised him
and uh but we had some great fights we
had some great fights up there they took
all the
all the athletics out of prison by you
know they
they don't have no more now now it's
just a a warehouse for insanity you know
they took all the weights out i don't
know
really you can't work out in prison
anymore well they got bars you just you
do
chit-ups and stuff so right um so so
every boxing match was an
exhibition about in in the prison
no the bouts with with inmates
were fights i think that was the
beginning of like
the tough mankind remember the tough man
contest that they used to have where a
guy
145 pounds might fight a guy 180
yeah well that's kind of where the
prison fights were
you you never knew who you were fighting
wow okay
so so and it was like full like boxing
gloves like tape
tape up the hands and in the ring with
the ref
how do you train do you just fight other
guys on the off time and
you know well you had a sparring and
spar i
when i stopped boxing i never thought i
always fought but
uh i had trained five
fighters and all of them won champions
and and uh uh
i would spar like five rounds with each
of them you know every day
or every other day or whenever because
that's the way people
people do time all kinds of ways you
play chess you read
you play handball you become baseball
football at the time that i was there
right
or you box and you just box you know
that's
i was such a great shape you know you
were like a vitamin pill
but now like like i said it's just a
warehouse for insanity you're just
doing time man um
and you were able to because you were
the boxing champion
that was how you were able to not ever
have to join any prison gangs
yeah well i got out in 1969
1972 was when the mafia really came into
power
you know and that's when 1971
that's when 69 is when they started
be coming up you know coming coming
coming now they're in power
but the mexican mafia wasn't
as big as it was so you know now it's
it's a force to be reckoned with if you
go to prison
now you got to get permission out here
to kill somebody
crazy yeah were you ever in san quentin
with any celebrities
yeah danny drew
i mean you were before you were ever
even in any movies
you were like a bonafide celebrity
within the prison
yeah right and that was kind of how you
ended up getting your first real role
right
like when uh you were you were just on a
set randomly like for some other cat
right and then the director says dude
you're dating me
up from the prison it wasn't director it
was eddie bunker
who is who was a prolific writer before
he passed away
if you want to read a good criminal
novel pick up
education of a felon right i read that
when i was 18.
and and i couldn't believe the stories
that were in there and then when you
when you mentioned them in the in the
documentary i was like oh [ __ ] like this
guy
was the real deal for real i remember
one time
when my kid gilbert was uh was uh
uh on the lamb you know and he called me
i need some money i went to give him
some money
and he was with like four of his friends
and uh
his friends me and eddie bunger went to
meet gilbert and
we saw him and uh we handed out gave him
some money and be cool be careful
and then he'll come over to my house and
uh one of the kids what's the meanest
looking white dude i've ever seen
eddie bunker he had this he had this
even the way he talked
when he said hello it sounded like i
want to do a robbery
which is the way it was it was just he's
just this whole you want to do a robbery
you know just the way it sounded yeah
and uh and he said that's the meanest
little white man i've ever seen in my
life
and and so when i ran into him on
runaway train
he said trail you still boxing i go well
i
train i'm 40 years old i don't fight no
more
and he says we need somebody to train
one of the actors out of box
now they're giving you 50 bucks cash to
be extra right and uh
he leans over and says uh well they'll
pay you 320 a day
and i said how bad you want this guy
beat up no come back
i wasn't making three i was a drug
counselor i wasn't making 320 a week
you know what i mean how about you when
this guy beat up hopes and he goes
no no no no you got to be careful holmes
it's like he might suck you
i said he for 320 i could still
[ __ ] [ __ ] i didn't do that for free and
i started training eric roberts how to
box for a movie called runaway train
and eric in 1968 1985
was kind of a loose cannon you know he
was a movie star
you know movie star dick you know
and so i started training him and the
director kind of saw
that uh eric respected me
so he would do whatever i said and and
uh
andre kozlowski comes over to
you be in movie you
fight eric and movie and you be my
friend
and then he leans over and he kisses me
on both cheeks right
and walks away because he's like a
russian aristocrat and
first of all if you have a prison
background and somebody says be my
friend
it's like you can't wait a minute hold
on hold on
[Laughter]
and then and then he kissed me right he
walked away and i
looked at eddie hey look i'm gonna train
the kid for 320.
but if i'm gonna kiss that old man i
want more money
whoa you're european i didn't [ __ ] that
man
he says well they kissed and so so i
started training eric roberts for
the runaway train because they ask eric
who do you want
to to fight with you the guy they had
picked
was a pretty latin dude i mean he was
and eric roberts he prettier than
his sister you know i mean so so they
got
two pretty kids fighting in a
prison and it looked like the battle of
two queens you know so
so andre kept saying contrast
contrast he go to eric go ah
and then he come to me and go i turned
eddie is he clowning me and he goes
trail shut up and so i just i dummy but
i got a sag card and i trained eric
roberts
i fought eric roberts in the movie
runaway train and that's how i got
in the movies and the first five years
of my career
i played inmate number one bad guy
chicano dude tattooed dude
[Laughter]
i've never had a name the first name i
got was
art sanilla i played an italian in
death wish four with charles bronson i
got to meet
big charlie that's great that's great
yeah you ever get any fights on the
movie sets or people are pretty scared
of you
i've i've i've had to calm a few people
down and tell them i'll beat you to
death
[Laughter]
what was it did when you mentioned the
mexican mafia it reminded me of some
stuff that i saw in the news
not long ago where like the mexican
mafia was upset with somebody made the
movie was it uh
american history x or something like
that and you stepped in and
calmed everybody down it was uh
american me american me yeah yeah
american history x was backwards this
guy was
was a racist and then he goes into
prison
and he becomes a non-racist it's the
other way around
you go into prison non-racist you come
out
racist yeah that's the way it is and a
lot of the trouble
that we have out here with racism it
stems from prison
okay because that's because when they go
in they have to stick with their own
race and then like you kind of
just get indoctrinated go with the wrong
one and you're in trouble
right and so did i did i read that right
in the news that like that you like
smoothed everything over with the
mexican mafia and this movie guy
danny trejo holds nothing back when he's
talking about the mexican mafia
so why would i hold anything back when i
admit to you
that i got pretty fat recently because i
fell off the sugar wagon started eating
all this
candy and cake and just awful stuff and
it got
ugly really fast but i'm fighting back
i'm battling the bulge and you know how
i'm doing it
with my whoop strap what is it it's the
most
sophisticated fitness device and app
known to man it tells me everything that
i could want to know about my fitness
my health my sleep my recovery
and it is the most useful tool i could
possibly have
to get back in shape this summer and i
want you to get in shape with me man
so you're gonna go to woop.com that's
w-h-o-o-p-dot-com
and use the promo code stevo to get 15
off at checkout why are you gonna do
that you're gonna do that to get in
great shape and to know what is going on
with your health all right and how are
you gonna do it
you're gonna go to woop.com and use the
promo code
stevo you're gonna get your whoop strap
totally free
and 15 off your membership check out
so get on it go to woop.com
and let's hear about the mexican mafia
there's a there's a documentary uh
mundo one of the mexican mafia guys
did a documentary i forget what it's on
but he says danny trejo is
blessed he walks on both sides and that
was a hell of a compliment coming from
stone cold enforcer of the mafia but
but uh but uh it talks all about
edward james made some serious mistakes
man
you know you don't i would rather have a
mangy dog for a friend than an enemy
all right and and he just really
disrespected
some people that were still alive and
some people that were
that passed away that had good
reputations when they were alive
so he got in a lot of trouble so
he won't admit it but yeah i saved his
life
man i mean dude that's i remember
because it just
jogged my memory i was i remember
thinking dude danny trejo
just [ __ ] cleaning up some messes
with some
real heavy hitters some [ __ ] scary
[ __ ]
i thought man danny's for real one of
the guys that told me
because i got i i was doing a movie
called bloody
blood out which was taylor hackford
and i got offered a part in american me
by edward james
and uh me and eddie bunker went and
talked to him and his manager over at uh
what's that name of that restaurant on
ventura boulevard
uh there's casa vega true no no
there's two of them it's a it's a like a
jewish deli
enchanters
and there's another one what
jerry's deli come on
okay so and we went and we met him and
his manager there
and i didn't like it from the start
because he showed up
wearing like a a county jail shirt
and and county pants looking like in a
headband
looking like you know a cholo from east
l.a i'm telling you
hey hey we're encino [ __ ] with
the hell you doing and i you know he's
one of those guys that
has to stay in character you know and
and uh
and those guys they bugged me because
if you're playing a killer how do you
stay in character
that's fantastic so so uh
but so we talked and it was like we
asked him hey did you uh
did you clear this with joe morgan joe
morgan was like the leader
at the time you know the mexican mafia
and yeah
yeah yeah we did we did and that was a
red flag right there you know
me and eddie both looked at each other
we knew he had because joe morgan we
knew
you know and we knew that there's some
things in this strip that he would never
approve
so okay so anyway we left and then up
and then that afternoon i got a call
from joe morgan
well i got a call from my cousin sal who
was in the county jail
and joe morgan had come down from folsom
and
and they said uh my cousin called says
hey danny
do you know joe morgan yeah i know or
are you okay are you in trouble
because joe doesn't call anybody unless
it's we're gonna kill you
or uh you know did you get the stuff
it's like so i said no no i don't know
why what's up oh he wants you to go over
to eddie's at five
because he's going to call you so okay
so you get a call from it's not a good
you understand right we all have that
friend like getting called into the
principal's office
and and so he i go to eddie's eddie
answers to me hey yeah
he's right here almost what's up big joe
you know what's up
hey danny uh i understand you're up for
that movie
american me he found i had just gone
show you their pipeline i had just
met him at jerry's deli that morning
i got i was at eddie's getting a call
from him at five
geez now he's locked up
and uh yeah what i hear you up for that
movie yeah well i'm up for both of them
which one was what are you gonna do i
said i'm gonna do bloody and blood out
oh yeah that's the cute one i'll never
forget that because that's the cute one
it's all about murder prison gangs
he said yeah you know what because
there'll be a lot of trouble with that
other one that guy said he'd come up
here if he didn't visit me
i refused to see him so oh
i'm glad i didn't do it wow so on prison
movies
like in your consulting do you guys have
to sign off with like the the shot
callers to see if it's okay to like do
certain things
no we don't have to because we know
what's right and what's not
you know if they're gonna disrespect
somebody that's alive or somebody that's
dead
that you know wait a minute i
i remember when they were doing they
were doing a movie in venice
and they had a they were wanting to use
venice 13
this line and i remember i was driving
by
and i stopped and and i waited a minute
there's a movie set and i just stopped i
said what are you guys doing you see
this well uh well you because we're
you can't use that holmes that's that's
a real gang
like you want trouble with them you're
gonna
really oh blue then it's 15 good
you ain't more jesus it's and so so
basically bloody
blood out and american me were the same
subject matter
but one was la onda which was
my gang the other one was the mexican
mafia
that's a real gang you understand so
even though they were about the same
thing this one was fiction
this one wasn't you know eddie would
have been better to do a documentary
does leonda mean the wave the oh the
the way it was the way it was and
the problem with the american me the
main problem was that one of the
characters was raped in prison was that
what it was
rigged in juvenile hall yeah and then
was and that was a real person that
they're and it didn't
it didn't happen and then and then it
said that the
mexican mafia killed cheyenne they
didn't
the northern faction killed him you know
so
it was basically edward didn't
understand see that's the problem with
guys that have never been on the streets
writing a documentary about the streets
it said
wait a minute it's like i remember
saying
this is not facts
and him saying theatrically it really
works i said
you're not dealing with theatrical
people
yeah do you understand these guys will
kill you
this is the most fascinating yeah this
is it this is i can't even understand it
this is so fascinating
what what was your workout routine in
jail i mean how many push-ups are you
doing how many sit-ups
cause you you were pretty jacked you
still are but i mean
all day all you worked out all day the
way i did my time
was working out so if i pass the bar i
just start doing
pull ups if i pass this the [ __ ] up
crunch i start doing you know just
that's what you do you do all day so
basically that's one of the things that
killed me when i came out here to box
i did
time exercising training that's the way
i did my time
out here i'm running it five o'clock in
the morning thinking
these people aren't even awake yet
because
i'm not doing time you know so the
hardest thing for me to do
was stay in shape i started boxing
howie steinler literally said uh
danny you'd be you could be a champ man
but you got to work out
i would go in the train with a client
from narcotics prevention project
that i had to take to the hospital so
hey let's hurry up let's train this you
know
let me get these five rounds in so it
was
boxing you have one god and that's
boxing
that god is a very jealous god if you
try to do anything else
you look at everybody that's tried to do
something ronda rousey
yeah the greatest mma fighters ever
she could still be fighting
if she didn't start modeling if she
didn't start
you know uh uh movies doing movies
i mean i'm serious it's like you know
nobody could beat her
what he would man with the rapper yeah
tyron woodley
hey if i'm getting paid
160 000 for my face on the cover of
bitchin magazine
and i go into a fight last thing i want
to do is break my nose
yeah you know i mean so it's like it's
like you can't that's it that's all you
do
and uh i came out here i got into
club fighting and that was just going to
the red barn going to see
going to wherever and it was kind of
like a tough man contest
but you made like 600 a week or some
cash and
every once in a while they're training a
kid and they would say something like
uh hey we're trying to bring this kid
along he's going to go pros
put a couple hundred in the envelope
i'll
i'll give him a good fight and
then i became a good actor so
good um so now you got sober
in prison yeah 1968
i came out of the pen well i came out of
the hole and uh
and i just asked god to let me die with
dignity and i'll say his name every day
and i'll do whatever i can for my fellow
inmate and i got kicked out of the hole
and uh so i started doing i just started
i became
chairman of aaa i became a inmate social
catalyst and
i just started doing whatever i could
for my fellow inmate i said inmate
because i never thought i was getting
out of prison
you know and the parole board
mad dog madden that's his real name said
uh
said give you know what we're gonna give
you a rabb
give you um 30 days get out of here
bring us back a life sentence i'll never
forget that said it so calmly
bring us back a life sentence in other
words i had a 10 year top
so that's all they had me for so like
i signed coming back and i remember i
was that's it
now i got to learn how to be a nice guy
such a good deal man were you like not
like were you shooting up like while you
were boxing
and like you would go and like would you
ever go hide a box or
i did everything yeah i shot i
shot heroin and boxed you know i drank
in the box
yeah i drank bruno which is the worst
thing in the world
if anybody out there drank bruno you're
a damn alcoholic okay
yeah it's so funny when i go to prisons
and i talk
about alcoholism and drug devices you
know what let me tell you something
if you guys in here anybody here drinks
bruno you're an alcoholic okay
because if you've got to drink that
stuff it's your [ __ ] up homes it's
worst tasting [ __ ] in the world and uh
but it'll get you drunk
so that's i talk about that and i i
fought loaded i bought a load on heroin
and you know i fought drunk
got got hit up pretty good but it's all
right
yeah yeah and this um the hole you're
talking about when you got out of the
hole was that like
solitary yeah you were in solitary for
like three months or something like that
ain't nothing my my cousin did 16 years
gilbert you know he went uh he went to
uh
the over stabbing the guard stayed 16
years
you know so and and in my time
you know like when you stayed in a hole
a month two months three month warming
that's a long time 18 months
mario stood four years my assistant the
guy that i met in san quentin
uh when i was doing bloody and blood out
he was a resident he refuses to be
called an inmate i was a resident
dude that's so good so were you it was
san quentin like
the top tier place you don't want to go
without alcatraz was going on at that
time
well no uh they they they closed
alcatraz in 63
and uh uh it was
alcatraz was just like san quentin it's
just freezing
but visits were harder that's that's the
thing about
about prisons location location located
it's like like it's funny because like
mario
was uh not a uh
not a or what do you call it when you're
good
not a model prisoner so they sent him
like southern california you want to
stay in southern california
because northern california is there's
there's a factions there's surenos
surenos and nortenos
they fight so if you're not well liked
by prison
they send you to san quentin if you're
from southern california
because you're already marked you
understand it's like
if you're not liked in northern
california they'll send you southern
california
so uh you have problems and and uh
mario was sent to to
san quentin so when i i when i'm there
doing bloody blood out
nortenos all wear red they're all
wearing red yeah and so
i look out and i see two guys in blue
shorts
and i'm thinking what's wrong with this
picture
you know so i went out and i started
talking to him and then yeah you know
from
baldwin park yeah we got to represent
you know
isaac you got stabbed yeah we have fist
fight a couple times
but but this basically hold their mud
and don't
uh disrespect
their flag or disrespect them or you
know stay to yourself
so they were all right but i said well
come do this movie and he kind of told
me well you know what
the mafia kind of said nobody
you know nobody from the from the south
movies
with the american me thing it made such
an old movie why did that just come up
in the news so recently
uh because people didn't forget it and
i think maybe they i think they killed
somebody that had a
something to deal with that and yeah
that's right yeah a couple people
i think maybe got killed over that and
that's what made it recent
so dude just trying to add it up you
said you got sober in 68
so so you've been sober for 52 53 years
be 53 august 23rd man congratulations to
yeah i mean i think uh last thing i
worry about is anonymity
my query came out the front page of the
times you know so it's like
it's so funny i met my mom and sister
i got busted in 1965 and it came out all
over the paper right when i got busted
i hadn't seen my mom and sister since i
was three years old
so they came up to the county jail to
visit me
and that's that's actually where i met
my mom and my sister was
the visiting room of the county jail so
oh wow that was kind of like
weird oh wow i uh
don't really um maybe i should say when
i got sober it was a pretty public
ordeal as well
and um you know still though i
i i think that like the whole traditions
of anonymity
for me it's uh it just becomes
a little bit slippery like with your
what your motives are
because like for example there was one
time when uh
my agent brought me something they said
oh like they've got this
the school that wants to uh pay you to
come
and do like a q a on mental health and i
didn't
i didn't even think twice about it but
when i did the q a like
every question i would kind of say
like i would say you know i i really
don't i have experience with this type
of mental health you know like i come at
this from uh
you know 12-step sobriety kind of thing
and so
it really automatically i kind of was
just talking about 12-step sobriety
for money and that's where i remember
what like when i got done i felt like ah
you know like that's that's just like
myself i use
i use the 12 steps in every area of my
life
and it was like i wasn't the first one
to break my anonymity the papers were
and
you know like i i it it's the thing is
the thing is is i'm not selling uh
yeah stickers or books or
stuff on on but i will say yeah i'm a
member of
alcoholics anonymous and i'm a member of
of uh
narcotics anonymous and i'm a member of
anonymous
all that you know what i mean right
pandemic i had so much [ __ ] up my nose
you know they could test you every time
you're you're going to be on a set
i mean am i doing cocaine i give one
more love [ __ ] up
yeah i mean you're one guy you're one
guy i do not worry about
thank god but the thing is is i uh i
just uh
like i go and i'm it's funny because if
you look
in juvenile hall there's there's
probably
10 percent of the kids in juvenile hall
have an alcohol and a drug problem you
know
i thank god i i took my kids
to a a and n a with me all the time
right
and so they weren't ignorant
of sobriety that's what i got to say i
did they might have hated the
room while they were going but
i think when it came time for them to
give it up they knew where to go
right you know what i mean the safest
plan
my son told me dad i went to so many a
meetings the first time i smoked weed
i felt like i slipped
that's great i had uh that i had a
little fellowship
uh conversation after a meeting one time
and this lady she said uh she
just said to to the group said you know
i've got this kid i forget how old he
was maybe he was like
eight or nine some ten she said he shows
all the signs of uh of being an
alcoholic and i just see it it's all
there but he's never even had a drink
yet i mean what do i do she says
i feel like i wanna hand the kid a
[ __ ] drink in a joint and say
hurry up get on with it so that he can
hit bottom and then get sober
i mean you know what i mean i think uh
addiction there's a there's there's a
part of addiction
that's in everybody sure everybody
addicted to model cars addicted to
this oh i love this and right now it's
like there's so many kids addicted to
the
to the uh video games cell phones video
games
yeah yeah well it's hard it's hard when
people's lives are unmanageable and they
don't even do drugs or alcohol you're
like
i don't even know what to tell you you
know i work with a lot of younger guys
and
they're like you know i think i have a
problem but they're like 17 18 and i'm
just like
i i don't even know you know it's like
it's it's it's hard to like
kind of say if you're an alcoholic or
not if you know until you're like
you know what if you're addicted to
anything it's like you just gotta get
interested in something else and that's
the hardest thing in the world
to get somebody to do something healthy
some have something healthy you know i
mean i love the program
the program is so wealthy i'm now the
fact we're opening up to me
i went to a meeting
yesterday till last night no night
anyway last night before last
you know so i'm now we're meetings are
opening up again i'm
so glad yeah yeah man indeed i'm right
there with you and i couldn't be more
grateful dude
i could not be more grateful and and uh
i do believe you've heard me say this
before but
i am particularly grateful that i got
alcoholism
so bad that i had to do something about
it because
exactly the worst thing i can imagine
would be to just kind of have alcoholism
just bad enough that it can screw up my
relationships
stop me from accomplishing what i want
to accomplish just make
just make me just [ __ ] ineffective
at my life and then all my years slipped
through my fingers and
the years turned into decades but that
didn't happen to me man because i had
alcohol it was so [ __ ] bad
and now i'm sitting here with like the
last 13 years
i i've not wasted time or resources
on [ __ ] [ __ ] that just causes
wreckage i've been pretty focused on
what i want to do
and man my life is good i just you know
what it's it's
like what you're saying i you know my
life is just
moved just goes on i don't i don't even
know what i'm doing
nine times you know i mean my driver
just came in and i had to leave me like
what am i doing oh you got to say oh
okay all right
i didn't know i was going anywhere yeah
but but that's the way
who cares is i uh it takes about four
people to run my life
and i'm glad because otherwise you know
that's just i wouldn't know it i'd be
out there working on a car
dude i i love it so much man it takes a
number of people to run my life too
but that's a quality problem
your dog's like i'll mine her asleep too
right
you know i found this dog in the streets
of peru brought her home
really yeah i brought her home from peru
man this is my girl
so so uh you know i want to ask you one
more question and then
and then uh you know get clear on what
what it is that we're promoting for you
but i'm just dying to know you got the
acting
you got the restaurants you got
the the book right i said this is your
first book it can't be your first book
that first book that's your first book
okay so
i got the record label too i got a
record label oh how about that nice
that's killing it we just we just went
down to pomona
and entertained all these little kids
down there uh
that are immigrants that are being
housed there and they loved you some of
them kids
hadn't smiled since they've been there
they were cracking up and singing with
us
and on the 24th we're going to long
beach
to uh sing for those kids you know so
that's great man um how how is the
the restaurant stacking up against the
acting
for
[Laughter]
my secretary she knows or gloria
my age i don't even know as long as they
could as long as i can go to the ready
tell her i'm cool
ah dude that's that that's good that's
the best and do you sell
merch danny absolutely the restaurant
trails tacos and
uh trails cantina and trails
i don't drink and i sell beer
on my car i got i got a comedy tour and
i don't drink and i got my audience
[ __ ] breaks the records every time
my audience drinks more [ __ ] alcohol
than anybody else coming through these
places i do shows at
just make sure you have some literature
on the way out yeah
you know you can always tell too man
like the people who are really
disruptive at the show
speaker yelling out y'all wanna say man
saving a seat for you
okay so so we got the book coming out
it's already out as of the publication
of this podcast
july 30 yeah yeah and so we don't give a
[ __ ]
where you buy it but just make sure you
get your hands on that book
right yeah and uh and if you're if
you're in l.a is it
trejos tacos chairs cantina this is only
in l.a
both trails tacos or trails cantina are
we going to expand to any other states
and
well we got one yeah we got florida we
got uh chicago
we got ghost yeah ghost kitchens
but here we just opened one in santa
monica
on third and uh santa monica boulevard
right by the promenade
i can't dare that was pretty that's
gotta be a a
expensive rent yeah but uh
i don't ask mary i don't know
do you get something on the menu every
time or do they make something special
for you
yeah i did you know what what's cool i
eat for free man and they
i can uh order whatever i want and
basically
the restaurants if you go in there hey
could you do yeah yeah
you're cool so what's your order what do
you order when you go nachos
so [ __ ] and what i do i order nachos
and two eggs on top
that way i kill lunch and breakfast at
the same time so that's the trejo
special
trail special yeah i got a dude
we're going to trejos right after this
all right cool i i i love it
um what about social media like are you
on all there yeah we're on all of them
we're on everything
okay i'm gonna find i'm gonna find you
on there dude and i'm gonna finish sorry
what uh what else can we point people to
we got every single social media
platform to follow you on we got the
book to buy
right now we got the restaurants to eat
at
and record label and by
we're getting ready to drop another
album called trail soul classics
label the record the sound is chicano
soul classics
and do you have any movies coming out
yeah but they're the ones you can't talk
about i got about let me see so that
means they're a big deal dude
secret movie yeah how are you doing i'm
gonna cartoon big city greens
i love that one all right yeah and i
i want to point people towards your
daughters you know
valentino i'm in that cartoon too and
then movies are uh
minions
i'm in the minions nice i mean spongebob
squarepants
thank god hey check this out i was doing
the
i went to super bowl right and uh
snoop dogg was performing and he calls
me
up come here danny i'll come in and i
can walk up onto the stage right
and it's an open mic i didn't know it
right and he goes
joe this is a [ __ ] two of the oldest
gangsters in hollywood
and we're in spongebob squarepants that
everybody just went nuts
[Laughter]
i love that dude that's cool wow wait
danny i got to ask i mean you're
you're 77 years old is that correct and
you are
thriving you have so much going on
you're you're showing no signs of
slowing down
is there any secret to that or or
exercise exercise right exercise
help other people oh yeah the only vice
i have is tostitos
chips
oh man damn dude it's uh yeah it's
inspiring to watch
it's it's inspiring as [ __ ] man i really
do i
i was so happy to to learn that we were
gonna get to do this with you man
and uh dude i appreciate it i really i
really
do um god bless you man yeah
god bless you dude you see it at the
restaurant homie hell yeah thank you
danny
respect how about that huh i don't know
what i enjoyed more
the podcast or the spicy shrimp burrito
bowl i got from trejos tacos afterwards
but man it is all good stuff and here we
are you know i love you people
the wonderful people who stick around to
the very
end and i don't have anything to tell
you guys
except i love you man and i feel like
this podcast is just getting
really good man thank you for watching
you